[Music]  why would he pick a girl like me to  marry I don't know that sounds ominous  what's in this room everything I've  shown you the arch the jewels the  clothes all of it is for you  the only off-limits room is this one  I'm just so curious sometimes it feels  like my mind is just one question after  another  do you ever get fight  as a lovely young wife young and lovely  I'd like to make a phone call yes they  put the line was dead  where happens all the time here let me  hear you say it's done I disagree  what am i he went into the room he told  you not to go into did you know you  should get as far away from here as  possible Elizabeth I think husbands and  wives should always be truthful wouldn't  you agree  my point  you